übermorgen wird es aber mal richtig
spannend schafft es Berlin unser
Kalkutta an der Spree
diesmal so was ähnliches wie eine
ordnungsgemäße Wahl abzuhalten sie
wissen die letzte vom September muss
wiederholt werden wegen was hatten wir
alles fehlender Wahlzettel mehr Stimmen
als Wahlberechtigter und allgemeiner
Doofheit und ich will wirklich nicht
unten aber wenn es noch mal schief geht
muss man die Stadt sehr wahrscheinlich
insgesamt abschaffen oder
abreißen keine Ahnung die haben also
noch genau eine Patrone im Lauf beim
zweiten Versuch muss alles klappen doch
stattdessen liefert die Hauptstadt neue
Pannen neue Schlagzeilen so wurde auf
den englischsprachigen
Wahlbenachrichtigungen einfach ein
falsches Datum angegeben und die
Berliner CDU ließ für die Landeswahlen
versehentlich noch einmal
exkanzlerkandidatieren
denn wenn ein Gesicht für Erfolg steht
meine Damen und
kann ja wohl das hier ach Kinder
Wiederholungswahl im Februar das ist
mutig Hochgepokert denn wissen Sie um
diese Jahreszeit ist Berlin natürlich
ein zugiges dunkles Höllenloch
voll mit halb gefrorenem aus alten
Böllern und Hundescheiße ich will sagen
die Laune ist wahrscheinlich noch
schlechter als sonst extrem aufregender
Wahlkrimi regiert am Ende rot rot grün
Berlin oder doch grün rot rot ne ja so
lauten aktuell die realistischen
koalitionsalternativen dabei liegt die
CDU in den Umfragen vorn und sie hat mit
Abstand den lustigsten Spitzenkandidaten
was der raus Auto weil ich will nicht
dass die Leute über uns lachen sondern
dass sie mit Berlin Lachen das in Berlin
Vorbild wieder ist und dass die Leute
irgendwann mal sagen dass er Wahnsinn
die haben eine funktionierende
Verwaltung
oh Entschuldigung Herr Wegner ich lach
wirklich nicht mit dir ich lach über
dich
funktionierende Verwaltung aktuell sind
nur noch 24 Prozent der Berliner
zufrieden mit Rot-Rot-Grün alias r2g
also nennt man die ja auch und die und
die Beliebtheitswerte der regierenden
Bürgermeisterin Franziska Giffey sind
auch im Keller was man so liest was ein
bisschen unfair ist weil die Frau hatte
ja nur anderthalb Jahre Zeit was zu
ändern irgendwas zu ändern in dieser
Karikatur einer Hauptstadt tatsächlich
ist Frau Giffey immer noch eins der
größten Talente der SPD und
selbstverständlich hat sie auch glühende
Anhänger ja ich habe Willy Brandt
gesehen
jetzt die erste Frau
ja genau aber da haben wir uns dran
gewöhnt dass die Frauen überall
mitmischen
erst gehen wir in den Wahlrecht und
jetzt wollen sie selber gewählt werden
du kleiner Finger ganzer Hand übrigens
übrigens letzten Dienstag hat Frau
giffeis Regierung eine große
Verwaltungsreform vorgestellt die
endlich das Absurde Behörden Ping Pong
zwischen Senat und Berliner Bezirken
beenden soll ulkiger Zufall so kurz vor
Schluss fällt Ihnen das ein sachen
gibt's ja direkt vor der teuersten
Berlinwahl aller Zeiten kostet 39
Millionen Euro
die sind doch der größte netto-empfänger
des Länderfinanzausgleichs und dann 39
Millionen wofür
wahlhelferschulung
42.000 davon braucht Berlin mehr denn je
um zu motivieren wurde das sogenannte
Erfrischungsgeld erhöht von 60 auf 240
Euro für den Wahlsonntag
also
240 Euro Tagessatz oder wie manche
Berlin das sagen nie wieder arbeiten
zum Vergleich mal in Brandenburg also im
Prinzip drei Spargelfelder weiter
kriegen Wahlhelfer maximal 45 €. aber
gut hoffentlich haben sie für das viele
Geld diesmal auch genug Wahlzettel
gekauft was sagt denn der neue
Wahlleiter ist der wenigstens gute
Hoffnung dass alles glatt geht die
Uhrzeit wird ja keine Wahlbeobachter
entsenden ich hatte das ja angeregt und
mir gewünscht
zum Mitschreiben der Wahlleiter von
Berlin hat internationale Wahlbeobachter
angefordert im Sinne von uns würde mich
freuen
ja die OSZE schickt aber kein also
Entschuldigung muss mich korrigieren die
hatten wohl einen Beobachter nach Berlin
geschickt der wollte dann mit den Öffis
ins Regierungsviertel aber wie denn wenn
nicht mal der Schienenersatzverkehr
fährt also hat das zu Fuß versucht
schwierig ne in Berlin wegen dem ganzen
illegalen Müll der darüber rumliegt dann
wurde er um ein Haar von einem
Pizzakurier übergemangelt
ja drei Meter weiterhin der erste Dealer
Crackpfeife angeboten und weil er nicht
wusste was das ist hat er dran gezogen
seitdem feiert der US den Ehemann die
Nächte im Berg kein durch ne und
tagsüber geht dann natürlich auf den
Strich
blöd gelaufen aber ist uns allen schon
passiert
wir stellen fest in einigen Punkten
bleibt Berlin sich eher treu zum
Beispiel so hört man dauert es nach wie
vor ewig bis man einen Termin bei
irgendeinem Berliner Amt kriegt da
werden im Warteraum angeblich Kinder
gezeugt und geboren
aber kennen wir noch als alte ddr-phrase
es war nicht alles schlecht die
Entlastung der Bürger in Energiekrise
zum Beispiel Stichwort 29 Euro Ticket
gute organisierte Hilfe für geflüchtete
aus der Ukraine und als im letzten
Sommer an vielen Flughäfen Chaos
herrschte hat sich ausgerechnet der ber
gut geschlagen ja so aber jetzt kommt
der eigentliche Knüller pünktlich zum
Valentinstag behauptet eine neue Studie
die auf Umfragen basiert Berlin sei
Deutschlands romantische Stadt
ja warum auch nicht meine Heiratsantrag
im Schein eines brennenden SUVs ist mal
was anderes ne hier der Vergleich mit
anderen romantikmetropolen
in Venedig sinkt der Gondoliere für die
Verliebten oh solemio in Berlin hört man
an der Ampel aus dem AMG Mercedes
Haftbefehl
kann man vorm Rockefeller Center
gemeinsam Schlittschuhlaufen in Berlin
rutscht man allein auf Döner Kotze aus
in Paris holt man sich morgens warmes
Baguette Team oh share in Berlin
bestellt man Brötchen und der Bäcker
sagt einem Detail du kackvogel
hat alles seinen Charme finde ich achten
Sie mal drauf die Berichterstattung über
das kaputte Berlin ist inzwischen so was
wie ein eigenes journalistisches Genre
statt auch über das zu reden was klappt
wir schalten deshalb mal live zu unserer
Reporterin Gisa Flake zum Cottbusser Tor
wo seit kurzem eine echte Berliner
Erfolgsgeschichte zu gestauen ist das
kann man wohl sagen Oliver das hinter
mir ist quasi der Quantensprung im
notdurftbereich nach und das ist
ausdrücklich kein Witz nur fünf Jahren
Planungszeit hat der Kotti eine
öffentliche Toilette
hochemotionale Einweihung ich kann Ihnen
sagen die ganzen Junkies hier hatten
Tränen in den Augen natürlich aber damit
wir uns richtig verstehen fünf Jahre
Planung für ein Scheißhaus ja nee nicht
irgendein Scheißhaus die Bretterbude ist
ein missoir ganz was Neues deswegen hat
die grüne Bürgermeisterin von Kreuzberg
ja auch stolz getwittert
BAM da ist das Ding seit fünf Jahren
wird eine Toilette am Kotti gefordert
jetzt ist sie da
und wenn sie als gelernter Show wie sich
jetzt fragen was bitte ist ein missoir
das ist eine hochkomplexe Geschichte ich
denke die Erfinderin kann es besser
erklären es muss zwar ist von den Hock
Toiletten abgeleitet aber für den
originalen Gebrauch der Frau angepasst
das heißt es hat eine andere Form und es
hat einen spritzschutzgitter
also letztlich ein Loch im Boden mit dem
Gitter drüber
ja aber mit Haltestangen signorant
tatsächlich eine super Erfindung denn im
Gegensatz zu penisbesitzern müssen wir
ja für die paar versifften sitzt
Toiletten ewig anstehen und bezahlen und
jetzt kommt die Urinale Wende die
allermeisten Frauen ich finde selber
eine ist das ein entscheidender Punkt um
öffentliche Toiletten zu benutzen ist
dass die halbwegs gut sind sauber sind
ordentlich sind ja nee klar nur Frauen
mögen saubere Kloster
wir sind super wenn man auf dem Weg zur
Schüssel durch Knie tiefen Morast wartet
ist doch so Männer fühlen sich nur zu
Hause wenn stinkt und Berlin macht sich
zum Horst selbst wenn sie mal was
richtig machen mein gott stellt die
Dinge halt überall auf aber macht sich
so ein geschichtstrom geschissen haben
Sie gemerkt das war ein Wortspiel habe
ich meine jedes Berlin Klischee wird
immer neu bestätigt Michael Müller
ehemaliger regierender hat jetzt erzählt
dass er über Jahre vergeblich versucht
hat eine Laterne vor seinem Rathaus
abzuschalten die Tag und Nacht gebrannt
hat ging nicht wegen unklarer zus
Öffentlichkeit ja das stimmt da wurden
mehrere Arbeitsgruppen gegründet bis
dann die Taskforce Laterne endlich die
rettende Idee hatte
welke diese Stadt kann sich nicht selber
helfen Helmut Schmidt hat schon 2003
vorgeschlagen Berlin unter
Bundesverwaltung zu stellen hat nicht
geklappt nächste Idee die Alliierten
kommen zurück außer Putin wollte keiner
jetzt wird alles gut denn haben sie
gehört wer ab sofort die Verwaltung
übernimmt der Abu chaka-clan genial die
wissen wie man seinen Kiez kontrolliert
oh mist da kommt direkt einer hallo Herr
zacka
sie wollen bestimmt meine
Drehgenehmigung sehen ich würde die
jetzt mal kurz aus dem Auto ganz schnell
kann meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank
falls Sie das gruselig fanden sie
eigentlich schon die Schockmeldung
schlechthin mitbekommen wooia Europas
größter Vermieter baut erstmal keine
neuen Wohnung mehr warum weil es sich
einfach nicht mehr rentiert ja ja
die konnten die konnten ihren Aktionär
nur noch eine Dividende von 7,1%
ausschütten tragisch ja Heuchler ja
meine klar mit denen hat jetzt keiner
Mitleid aber leider hören andere auch
aufzubauen weil Bauzinsen und
Materialkosten bei uns durch die Decke
gehen dabei hatte Olaf Scholz uns doch
mindestens 400.000 neue Wohnungen pro
Jahr versprochen war doch so ja so wenn
man wenn man aber nachguckt
2022 waren es wohl nur geschätzte
280.000 Tendenz klar fallt letzten
Oktober so lange ist das nicht her hat
der Kanzler zum großen Bündnis
bezahlbarer Wohnraum geladen mit sehr
wenig konkreten Ergebnissen aber noch
schön Pressekonferenz die Entwicklung
hat sich zum Ziel gesetzt ausreichend
Wohnraum in Deutschland zu schaffen mit
400.000 neuen Wohnungen als Ziel wir
wollen diese Zielsetzung verfolgen um
das Ziel zu erreichen wir halten an dem
Ziel fest dass das Ziel vereinbar ist
mit unseren Ausbauzielen und das muss
nämlich unser Ziel sein
wie schön oder man sagt ja nicht umsonst
das Ziel ist der Weg oder so ähnlich
leider sind viele aber keine Politik
zumal die Bauwirtschaft im Olaf noch am
selben Tag erklärt hat dass das Ziel so
nicht zu schaffen ist schon jetzt fehlen
mindestens 700.000 Wohnungen dabei hat
die Ampel mit klarer Gallwitz endlich
wieder ein Ministerium nur fürs Bauen ja
so an sich gut aber auch sie hat im
Herbst erstmal behauptet 400.000 sind zu
schaffen kurz danach hieß es wir nähern
uns der Zahl an und jetzt geht sie gar
keine Prognose mehr ab wie will man so
denn sein Ziel erreichen ja ich weiß ja
nicht was sie unter Ziel verstehen für
mich ist ein Ziel etwas was ich
erreichen will
ganz neue Ansatz muss ich sagen warum
hat die Ampel trotz massiver Wohnungsnot
die staatlichen Zuschüsse für Neubauten
gesenkt echt blödes Timing im ersten
Halbjahr 22 gab es dafür nämlich noch 10
Milliarden Euro jetzt nur noch eine
deswegen hat ein Bauunternehmer den
Kanzler gerade gefragt bei so einer
bürgerrunde wie seine Branche noch
planen soll worauf der Scholz
schlagfertig entgegnet ja schon Dank
zunächst mal
wir haben Deutschland schon mal 800.000
Wohnungen gebaut in einem Jahr 1972
ja
wie schön für die Menschen die im Jahr
1972 Leben
sonst kann er sich ja nichts erinnern
aber 72 hat doch noch drauf
vor allem der soziale Wohnungsbau kommt
hier fast völlig zum Erliegen weil er
sich für die Bauwirtschaft nicht mehr
rechnet um die Kosten zu decken müsste
man heute unsoziale Quadratmeterpreise
nehmen heute hätten mehr als 11
Millionen deutsche Haushalte Anspruch
auf eine Sozialwohnung aber nur für ein
Zehntel davon sind welche vorhanden und
klar selber was bauen können sich selbst
normal verdienen schon lange nicht mehr
leisten ihr seid jung wollt eine Familie
gründen und träumt von den eigenen vier
Wänden dann haben wir einen ganz
wichtigen Tipp für euch vergesst es
einfach könnt ihr eh nicht bezahlen auf
diese Steine könnten sie bauen wenn's
welche gäbe es gibt aber keine Zement
leider auch nicht und keine Handwerker
diene Wärmepumpe einbauen jetzt nicht so
traurig wir können es doch nicht ändern
Schwäbisch Hall
ja
überraschend emotional Reaktion auf den
Toten Fuchs muss ich sagen also
Eigenheim ist nicht für die meisten also
bleibt was richtig nur mieten in den 14
größten deutschen Städten hat sich der
Mietanstieg im Vergleich zu den
Vorjahren zuletzt verdoppelt und da oben
drauf kommt jetzt noch der hässliche
neue Trend zur sogenannten Indexmiete
also einer Miete die an die Inflation
gekoppelt ist nicht schön nee da bist du
zweifach gearscht die höheren
Energiepreise die ich als Nebenkosten eh
schon bezahlt habe treiben die Inflation
die wiederum meine kaltmietet vielen
Dank auch ja die Grünen haben jetzt
gefordert bei indexmieten soll der Staat
regulieren eingreifen aber ich gebe mein
Tipp ab das ist mit der maklerpartei FDP
wohl nicht zu machen was bleibt also
mehr bauen und dafür endlich wie seit
Ewigkeiten versprochen unsere absurden
Bauvorschriften vereinfachen und
angleichen 16 verschiedene
Landesbauordnung es könnte man sofort
ändern wenn man wollte stattdessen
werden keinen Spaß immer nur neue
Kommissionen dafür gegründet was hatten
das alles 2015 die
baukostensenkungskommission die
schuftern aber nur die Arbeitsgruppe
Standards im Bauwesen die wiederum einen
sonderpräsidialausschuss bauen und
Gebäude gründete der danach wieder nur
den Präsidialausschuss Bauwerke ins
Leben rief und was macht Olaf Scholz
richtig ergründet die unabhängige Stelle
zur folgekostenabschätzung in
normungsprozessen
daher das bekannte T-Shirt ich wollte
bezahlbaren Wohnraum aber alles was ich
bekam war eine unabhängige Stelle zur
folgenkostenabschätzung
können sie nicht bestellen sage ich
gleich es ist kompletter Irrsinn ist
wirklich kompletter Irrsinn unsere
bauforschriften hier jetzt nicht im
heute show PlayStore
achtung jetzt neu nur für Hardcore Gamer
Landesbauordnung Simulator 23 ultra
realistisch um zu spielen brauchst du 16
Monitore und 16 Controller denn es gibt
ja 16 verschiedene
[Musik]
in Berlin muss eine Kellerwohnung 2,50 m
hoch sein in sechs anderen Ländern nur
2,40 m und im Rest von Deutschland nur
zwei Meter 30 Kämpfe gegen sage und
schreibe 16 schallschutzbestimmungen und
16 Brandschutzverordnungen bis zum
letzten Level wo sie dich endlich in die
Klapse bringen
Landesbauordnung Simulator 23 absolut
und spielbar
leider ja das könnte man sofort ändern
Ampel so meine Damen und die traurige
Realität ist um sich eine schöne Wohnung
leisten zu können müssen immer mehr
Deutsche einen Zweitjob annehmen Nancy
fazer zum Beispiel ja
schon diskutiert immer noch über unsere
Innenministerin weil die jetzt nebenbei
auch noch als Spitzenkandidatin der SPD
in Hessen Antritt der einzige Hesse in
unserem Team findet nicht gut
Gernot Hassknecht ist Hesse und
persönlich beleidigt gute
[Musik]
wegen Nancy fazer Hessen ist mit Abstand
des geilste Bundesland der Welt weiß
jeder Heimat von Goethe und Rudi Völler
wir haben die Parkscheibe erfunden und
den handcase mit Musik den einzigen Case
der gleichzeitig als chemische Waffe
gilt um die Dokumenta in Kassel beneide
uns an diese Mitte aus aller Welt und
jetzt kommt die Feder und sagt deswegen
trete ich an für mich ist Hessen
Herzensangelegenheit das ist meine ganze
Leidenschaft meine ganze Leidenschaft
daher werde ich für die
Spitzenkandidatur in Hessen ab sofort
mit ganzer Leidenschaft
halbtagsarbeiten die Frau brennt so für
Hessen dass sie in jedem Fall wieder hin
will also sei denn sie verliert die Wahl
dann können wir Bembel wenn sie nämlich
mal kreuzweise ich schaffe immer
Klarheit ich bin ehrlich und ich möchte
von vornherein sagen dass ich nicht als
Oppositionsführerin zurück nach Hessen
komme das war ich nämlich schon ach so
ja nee dann Schatz kannst du meinen Müll
runterbringen nee danke habe ich schon
mal gemacht fand ich scheiße nein
interessiert schon Hessen hier geht's um
mir Abwechslung im Lebenslauf von Nancy
Feser das müssen wir dann auch mal
einsehen wirklich hut ab so entwirtet
sie mal eben eine Landtagswahl und die
Opposition an sich Nancy du laberdüttel
für Hessen muss man alles geben immer
wie voll kaputt damals der ist zur Not
auf einem Huhn zur Arbeit geritten so
geht das wirklich nennt sie ich meins ja
gut mit dir aber was machst du da
garantiertes Rückfahrticket wenn man
verliert das geht in die Hose guck mal
wo der rechten heute ist
den ganzen Tag vor seinem Billy-Regal
trinkt Espresso und hofft dass endlich
einer anruft macht aber keiner willst du
so enden willst du das oder in der
Sprache unserer Heimat Frankfurt diese
Offenbach das ist doch wohl kein
nebelsaft auf einer arschback nur für
Hesse die Nummer fliegt hier in die
Fresse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen